like many mothers Tamara Peltier likes
taking videos of her son Thomas doing
cute things the 15 month old hangs
around with Mom and co-workers at the
family business Caribou water and he
likes helping haul the water jugs we
have the delivery truck come and go a
couple times a day and we load it up in
the morning and we unload it throughout
the day and he just watches and likes to
help pack the jugs around
Tamara posted video on Tick Tock and it
went wild over 30 million hits it's a
very amateur Tick Tock video and it just
exploded many like the toddler's work
ethic but comedian Howie Mandel posted
his apparently tongue-in-cheek view of
toddler labor he doesn't get any
benefits any health benefits
[Music]
he puts in a full work day
it's tough to get people working it's
tough to get kids involved and it just
that whole message just blew up I feel
co-workers are impressed by Thomas I
kind of joke sometimes that I think that
he knows this business better than we
all do
I move it move it but for Millions the
video is simply a cute diversion and to
those folks Thomas and Tamara say thank
you
Ted field Global News